let's get brexit done
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone warned that it would be the
beginning of the end that the status quo
was set to change and that brexit would
bring about the collapse of london's
powerful financial industry sooner or
later
it was said that frankfurt paris or even
amsterdam would succeed in unseating the
power of the city along with new york
one of the two most important financial
centres on the planet to give you an
idea approximately 2.5 times more
dollars are traded in the united kingdom
than in the united states now brexit is
already a reality and that has made us
here on visualpolitik along with our
friends at valley school ask a few
questions what influence does the city
of london really have in global finance
is the city as under threat as its
critics claim why is london along with
new york said to be the great financial
capital of the world well let's get
started
[Music]
strictly speaking the city of london
also known as the city or the square
mile is made up of the 33 boroughs that
make up greater london a district with
some special characteristics
[Music]
for example the city has its own
government and much more autonomy than
the other boroughs that make up greater
london in fact the city's municipal
corporation has 2 000 years of
self-government behind it it is the
oldest democratic formation on the
planet of course we are talking about a
somewhat unusual democracy because in
the city it's not only the physical
residents that vote but also the
companies through their employees in
fact due to this arrangement the
companies have more votes than the
residents themselves
[Music]
in any case if the city is known for one
thing it is for specialising in the
financial industry and giving its name
to one of the two most important
financial centres in the world between
the city and the canary wharf area they
have managed to get nearly 800 000
people working in highly skilled jobs
linked to the financial industry and
that expands to 2.3 million nationwide
it is what many call the last vestige of
the british empire so how important is
london really in the international
financial scene what role does it play
exactly well to answer these questions i
think the best thing to do is to put
some facts on the table
thanks to the city financial services
bring the uk a trade surplus of more
than 80 billion each year more than 100
billion if we take into account related
professional services such as law firms
or consultancy firms
neither singapore switzerland or even
the united states of america come close
to this figure just take a look
if you're a government or a large
company and you want to secure a large
loan you may have to go through london
nearly one-fifth of all international
bank lending and over 12 of all listed
international bonds originate from the
united kingdom and even more striking
more than 40 percent of the world's
currency trading also passes through
here more than 2.4 trillion dollars are
traded every day put another way 2.5
times more dollars are traded in the
united kingdom than in the united states
while the united states is also the
largest yuan trader outside of china and
that's not all with more than 200
established banks london's financial
industry is one of the world's largest
in private banking fund management
insurance and financial derivatives
derivatives that for example have also
made london one of the main trading
centers for commodities and energy
[Music]
then in terms of number of hedge funds
london is the second capital of the
world behind new york and if we're
talking about venture capital the
british capital is only surpassed
internationally by san francisco the big
apple and boston all this visualpolitik
fans is precisely what explains why this
industry generates a net income of more
than 100 billion dollars each year for
the united kingdom but at this point
many of you may be wondering but why the
city why has london become such an
important financial center well the
truth is that story goes back a long way
the times of the british empire london
became something like the nerve center
of the global economy a status that
favored the development of a huge
financial industry for example it was in
this city that the world's first
investment funds emerged in the second
half of the 19th century however despite
the empire falling the city kept its
prominence to explain this we could find
three major turning points the first of
these took place in the late 1950s at
that time european banks were beginning
to be overflowing with dollars the north
american giant was gobbling up a good
chunk of the world production and in
exchange was handing over uncle sam's
banknotes
well all this abundant availability of
funds and the fact that british
regulators decided not to interfere in
dollar denominated transactions between
foreign players led to the birth of the
euro dollar market in london a huge
market for financing and the exchange of
dollars that takes place outside the
united states and therefore is not
subject to the supervision of the
federal reserve or its cash requirements
nor to any guarantee on deposits or
anything of the sort we are therefore
talking about a much freer and cheaper
market
in this way the euro bond market grew to
become one of the pillars of the global
financial system and yes london became
the main euro bond center in the world
if you want financing in dollars it may
even be easier to get them in the
british market than in the united states
[Music]
the second turning point had to do with
decolonization the fall of the british
empire left many small territories
scattered around the world territories
that in some cases despite their
newfound autonomy retained their
political and economic ties with the
metropolis we are talking about places
like the cayman islands bermuda and the
virgin islands places that in order to
make money had options to become
important offshore financial centres we
are talking about places that guarantee
low taxes high legal security and
conditions of anonymity well thanks
precisely to their ties with the
metropolis much of their activity is
channeled and managed precisely through
london
[Music]
and finally the third turning point came
during the thatcher era when exchange
controls and a large part of the
financial regulations that existed at
the time were abolished this policy was
a real boost for a city that has
continued to grow ever since however
brexit unleashed the storm when on 23rd
of june 2016 british citizens voted to
leave the european union the foundations
of the city shook after the vote dire
predictions began to emerge about the
future of this finance industry the end
of london as a leading international
financial center seemed almost a fey
accompli of course prophecies do not
always come true listen up
the prophecy of destruction
london's role as the financial capital
of europe seemed about to come to an end
it seemed that banks and financial
institutions would run for cover and
move much of their business to the
european union even madrid set up its
own platform to try to get its share of
the spoils and indeed the first direct
consequence of brexit was that amsterdam
overtook london as the main trading
centre in europe of course the big
headlines were not long in coming
amsterdam overtakes london as europe's
leading stock market the city or
financial district of london has lost
its historical position as the main
enclave for the european market
overnight on first of january 2021 6
billion euros that's 6.8 billion us
dollars of daily trading moved from
london to the city of amsterdam to
comply with brussels regulations
[Music]
euronext the largest stock exchange
operator in the european union began
moving its data centers from essex to
bergamo italy it looked like the first
signs of a sinking ship in fact
according to estimates by jupiter a
leading asset manager the political risk
arising from brexit could have penalized
london listed companies at a 40 discount
to their international peers 40
however let's take a moment before
passing judgment because in spite of
everything things look much less
dramatic today
[Music]
the european union's efforts to reduce
its dependence on the united kingdom
does not seem to be paying off at the
moment london remains the main place to
raise capital from the old continent as
well as the dominant centre for foreign
exchange insurance and debt trading and
it doesn't look like that any of that is
going to change at least not in the
short term
in fact the london financial industry
has had its best year since 2007 in 2021
revenues grew strongly salaries in the
sector increased by almost 20 percent
and new estimates points to only 7 400
jobs moving to the continent this
represents less than one percent of the
jobs generated by the financial industry
in the british capital
[Music]
in addition we have to bear in mind that
whatever may happen with eu regulation
70 of the city's business does not
depend on the european union and so
visual politic viewers today the massive
financial services cluster developed in
london seems to have no competition
except in new york and there's even more
no longer bound by european regulation
the british authorities seem to be
working on a new plan to improve their
competitive position one example is the
so-called dark pools private systems
that allow large blocks of shares to be
bought and sold outside the public stock
exchanges it's a strategy that the eu
has tried to clamp down on but which
london seems to be making much more
flexible of course the city faces
significant challenges especially when
it comes to the stock markets
for example since 2010 the number of
international companies listed in london
has fallen from 599 to
and 370. as a result the number of
companies listed in london has fallen
from more than ten percent of the
world's market capitalization to just
over three percent however if one thing
seems clear it is that the prophecies
failed and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik all the best
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]